[Music]
people who are actually connected you
know
through whatever rituals or or whatever
um
they can sense when somebody is there
and one of the things he told us is he
said do not walk into communities with
people who just want to join you because
it's something cool to do their very
presence will weaken the the the
atmosphere of protection that you have
and it's visible
because when you guys walk into these
places you appear different to those
that are connected with spiritual
darkness
as christians we know that we're
involved in a spiritual war so what
tools can we use to fight in this battle
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live today first we'd
like to thank our donors out there
because without you guys we could not
exist so thank you all our patreon
supporters and there's different ways
you can support this ministry you can
support through patreon or you can
support through donating through
littlelightstudios.tv
or you can even wear your witness and
buy light wear t-shirts from
lightwear.shop so we just wanted to give
you guys a shout out and say thank you
today we're going to be talking with our
guest alex and levi this is kind of an
ongoing series we've been talking about
sex trafficking and just some of the
horrible things that are going on in the
world and y'all's involvement and
exposing some of this bringing some
awareness of this out there and we know
that we're involved in just this
spiritual war going on all around us so
i think you guys are going to be talking
about how we can implement this
spiritual warfare
uh prayer into everyday life right it
doesn't just have to be in sex
trafficking and things like that but
we're all involved in something we're
all affected by this spiritual war that
affects our lives so what are some
what's some good advice on how we can
fight in this battle well i think you
know one of the ways that
that
god revealed it to us that was real was
through the stark reality of
of human trafficking sometimes we can be
so desensitized and
stubborn that it's not until we see
something grand and crazy before we
recognize oh man this is real yeah but
you know if we if we come to the
conclusion that the battle is real then
all of a sudden we're like okay well how
does this this obviously
is is in everything that i do this is
obviously you know is important in every
aspect of my life this is not just some
you know the spiritual warfare only
happens with crazy things no spiritual
warfare happens in everything every
conflict that we have in in our
existence
and so kind of just i think
recognizing that it's real
is
is the first step and that's kind of
what we came to and so we were still
learning through this process
um
and and you know one of the one of the
things one of the stories where we ended
off last week was levi was sharing about
uh this group of young people that knew
that they were being called to to
witness they just didn't know how
and so here we are and we're trying to
teach them okay here's how you minister
to people in the streets and in reality
i think the greatest thing was how it
changed their mind
their
their change in attitude and approach
and their awareness to what was
happening is probably what i think was
the first step in their process to to
i don't know uh progressing in in that
spiritual conflict the same way that god
had revealed that to us and so
um they did they they agreed we got back
from you know uh we we had a
a talk where we where we were at a uh
during carnival we were at a kind of a
retreat
and we came back from that retreat
carnival was over we resumed kind of our
normal praying
um you'd have to watch the previous
episode to kind of get a little bit of a
overview of that and we're working with
these young people who now were
available to say listen god had already
revealed to us that we need to to
minister to to prostitutes in the street
how are we going to do it
you said that you used to do this in in
the states can you give us some pointers
can you teach us how we're supposed to
do this
and so we went to one of their houses
they all gathered together
uh we bought um man how many did we buy
is like 30 some 35 maybe roses or
something like that but it was it was
quite a lot of flowers that we bought
and a lot of cards and we said listen
you know write messages of of
encouragement you know things that that
let them know that they're someone of
worth of value of importance you're
thinking about them and a bible verse in
conjunction with that how how god cares
for them and loves them
and they began to write all these
personal messages and these cards we sat
there for like i don't know a little
over an hour and they were
they were all writing messages in these
cards and we filled out about i don't
know 30 40 cards and and we went to the
streets and we said all right
guys we're not going to do the talking
we're going to do the praying
watching make sure that everything's
okay somebody stays near the car
somebody stays on the corner of the
street keeps an eye you know one group
of two or three girls will go here one
group of two or three girls will go
there we're just there to make sure that
everything is covered in prayer and safe
not you know
hopefully nothing happens but we're not
necessarily there to intervene we
believe that god is the one intervening
but but we're there just in case yeah if
something happens
and just respond in the best way that we
know how
and so
within i think man 45 minutes less than
an hour all of the cards and flowers
were handed out
and that was really abnormal because my
experience in the states was when you go
out with like 15 or 20 flowers you're
out there for three hours and you come
back with half of them
you know because you're specifically
targeting a certain group of people yeah
processed prostitutes prostitutes so we
had the girls talk to the prostitutes
and the thing was that we knew that many
of the prostitutes on the streets were
actually men men dressed as women oh wow
because it's safer for men
to be on the streets than it is for
women because even if you're a
prostitute you can get kidnapped or
re-exploited in some other way and so a
lot of the girls would actually gather
around clubs or bars or stuff like that
where they had a relationship with the
owner
so that he'd be like yeah i just hang
around here and you kind of have like my
protection kind of thing and you just
bring in clients to my bar or whatever
my business is you know and so it would
be good for him because maybe some
people were looking for that type of
entertainment so he gets the clients
with the booze or whatever and
they get you know their
you know their client um but in many
cases when you see isolated sometimes
they're women sometimes they look like
women but they're not
and so
a lot of them will get surgeries and
whatever and and the reason that they'll
do it is because
once again their situation they can't
make money
as a man in certain situations they
could only make money if they prostitute
themselves and and so they'll either
become transvestite so they get sex
changes or all these kinds of stuff and
and you're like
and the kids know this and they're kind
of a little taken aback and they're like
ah we don't really we don't even know
why we want to do this we just know that
god has told us to do this so so they go
and they talk
and after the 45 minutes they all come
back and and like a number of them just
start breaking down crying
they come back and their parents are
coming out like okay so how it was how
was it like they were a little kind of
worried like were these guys taking you
out to go minister to prostitutes
whatever you know there's kind of some
okay we get their missionaries all right
it's fine go ahead and do it but you
know they're curious
so they come back and and the parents
are listening to their kids just like
mom dad we're so wrong
like how could we ignore these people
and they they needed to share it with
with their church and there was one
particular guy
whose name was was alexandria
alexander's the brazilian version of
alexander he was a man he was dressed as
a woman and he says you know what you
guys have treated me with so much
respect
i felt respected by you guys that i want
to tell you my real name not my street
name i won't tell you my real name
and and that's how they found out his
real name and they were they felt
convicted because they were telling the
church that
we didn't respect him like in our hearts
in our minds like we were looking at him
with like
like looking down and lay out a little
bit of disgust even you know and
but they still took that step forward
and they felt completely broken
they ended up getting uh i think
i don't remember the numbers five
requests for bibles and three requests
for bible studies something like that
from prostitutes
so they're like yeah i want to study the
bible please study oh i want a bible can
you get me one yeah and so they were
like we weren't expecting that everyone
accepted everyone was was loving
everybody accepted prayer
everybody hugged them and thanked them
for being there because the mindset is
like these people are too far gone they
don't they're rejecting christ they're
not going to hear this they're going to
turn us away or even be mean to us and
in reality those are the people who are
the most broken the most lost looking
for some kind of hope and light
and to know that somebody is going out
of their way to care for you or even pay
attention to you in a situation where
you feel like the only person that's
going to stop and talk to you is
somebody who's saying hey how much yeah
but but i think you know you could
easily see why people would justify that
like you know you're in a dangerous area
i don't want my kid walking around that
area and giving stuff out to them and
their parents had that same question all
those reasons why you shouldn't be there
but we trained them we trained them how
to do it in a way that that
you set certain boundaries
of safety and
good common sense and things like that
you know and and they they were willing
to listen and after we had went gone
with them and taken them through it when
we went to the following city in
fortaleza which was the fourth city um
there was nobody there that was willing
to to go through what we were we were
proposing
uh the pastor and the churches they were
kind of closing their doors to what we
were trying to do and fortaleza was one
of the worst cities and the name
actually means fortress and we felt like
it was a stronghold this is a strong
this is actually considered the number
one uh place for child sex tourism after
bangkok
so it's number two in the world it was
interesting actually when we were
because we took a bus there
and literally as soon as we stepped off
the bus alex and i
i asked him or he asked me one one or
the other
do you feel
weird here spiritually heavy here as
soon as we stepped off and i'm not like
the most particularly sensitive person
to those kinds of things it's happened
like one other time in my life but you
built a dark presence it was
super heavy there interesting every day
we were tired i was sick a few days yeah
you actually went up two days walking on
your own two hours wasn't two days yeah
um
but maybe you want to
share just one of those days
yeah there was just so you went out by
yourself one day well yeah he was sick
and we were just staying in a little
apartment with actually the pastor and
his wife there and uh
yeah one of the days
i went out and i was walking it was
during the daytime you know so
mo the way that city is arranged
is it's it's a little different than
other ones uh like we were saying in one
of the previous programs
most favelas are sort of like there's a
little alleyway off the main street and
you just go back and it opens up into
all these mounted on some hill somewhere
and like yeah you can tell where the
favela begins and ends with
some clear in this particular city
though was it it was a bit different
interspersed
so i was walking
through the main it was like the normal
nice part of the city downtown whatever
and i was by myself he was sick at the
apartment and um
i could see
there was
like a line like you could see where the
city
and the favela met
it wasn't an alleyway it was just like a
line right like it's here city and
here's favela yeah and
so i was getting kind of approaching you
know nearer to that area and i
i kind of prayed like
should i go in there you know i know
like we've been going in them
but
i'm by myself today is that really
something i should do on my own
but then i
i thought you know
god has to protect alex and i when we go
together
and if we're depending on him to to
protect us then god has to protect me if
i go it's all the same it's like it's
kind of like saying you know
god wants you to do something that costs
a million dollars it doesn't matter if
you have a thousand or a hundred yeah he
has to do it either way right
so
so like i i just prayed about it i said
um
this is why you brought us here and i
trust that you're gonna go with me just
like you'd go with us into any of these
places so i decided to go in
and pray for that area
and as i was approaching
the favela maybe you know 100 yards
before you could see like the the switch
a guy came up and
from i'm not sure where
and started to walk right next to me
and he was just talking talking talking
my ear off you know in portuguese and
we're still not too far into it so i
didn't i understood some but not all of
it but he's just talking and talking the
whole time
and uh he
continues to just walk with me and i
went into the the favela
he went in with me
and he actually showed me around took me
through it interesting introduced me to
people and stuff i don't know who this
guy is from anybody and he doesn't know
what well unless it was an angel you
know we don't know but
um
so we went through
he took me all through and i prayed for
the the people that i saw there and the
places and then we came back out
as soon as we came out he left and it
just like that um same day i was in
another place you know and i sat down
for a minute and it was like shooting
you know 500 yards from me wow and all
these cops with shotguns and dirt bikes
you know chasing the sky down the
alley beside where i was sitting
whatever so it was like it was a bad
city
and
this was i guess the second time where
god we went into one of these places in
this case by myself and he just
sent somebody to walk right beside and
to take me through
and
all the way until i i
left and that was it and then the person
left you know so
we don't know if it's if if that was an
angel or a just a person that he
inspired or whatever but nonetheless it
was like clear you know that was him he
didn't walk alone but this person wasn't
trying to like ask for money yeah you
know they're just like which is unusual
for people you meet you know in the
cities like that no he didn't ask for
anything he just went with me and
wow man wow it's like when you get to
heaven and you realize like your your
guardian angel comes up to you and
you're like hey
yeah i somehow feel that ours will be uh
super busy that's right
you've got a longer track record here
okay of us having interviews you're a
little
you're a bit of a liability
um so the thing is we we came to this
city and and and just as levi mentioned
like just the atmosphere was very
different
and the church said we're already doing
a lot of stuff we appreciate what you're
doing but i don't want you talking to my
church members about this
like i mean i'll introduce you to a
person here there within like leadership
that might be able to you know listen to
you guys but i don't want you to present
to my church
um
and he's very nice you've got to stay at
his house and whatever and we said we'll
even join you in what you're doing so
there were some times where they were
doing outreach and whatever and we
joined them in in that endeavor we
weren't like oh
it was none of that it was it was
actually very cordial very nice
uh we
we you know
we're trying to cooperate as much as
possible we understood that they were
uncomfortable with the idea of talking
about prostitution whatever
and um well the the pastor's wife had
actually sat down with us at one point
and
she asked us
why are you guys
like what's the point of going out to
approach people in the streets
and and say that we're going to try to
help them if we don't have any
infrastructure to help them with
like she didn't understand
going out to do something before you had
the means and we basically told her well
yeah you know why build infrastructure
on the we can flip the question right i
build the infrastructure if you don't
have the people right and once you have
them isn't god gonna provide
means you know to to help them right in
my mind like people had been praying for
years in atlanta before somebody said i
went off the street and they were like
okay well what do we do now and so the
infrastructure was built around the need
and so the thing is if people don't see
that there's a need why would they build
a rescue center right so why would they
train people why would they you know
like there's no reason to build you know
if there's nobody that's actually
reaching out and they don't see a demand
they don't see like a reason to do it
and so but you know it was it was fine
like we weren't
you know
sure
we wish we could have done more with
them but
but something something worked out
anyway where
um god sent somebody into that church
while levi and i were out um it was on a
monday i think
yeah so when we met we met this guy
named well we didn't meet him on monday
we met him on thursday
then we got him on thursday he came into
the church on monday
and he basically said that he needed to
get a ticket to sao paulo which is far
away he needed to return there and would
they give him money for the ticket and
the pastor was there and he said well
we're not going to give you money um but
we can buy you the ticket if your views
are something you can do right and so
what do you what what skills do you have
he says well i can paint
i mean we weren't planning on it right
now but we could paint the sanctuary so
we'll buy the paint and if you can paint
it
right we'll buy you the ticket to go
back to sao paulo you can stay at the
church and we'll feed you so
deal let's do it
and so during that week the the pastor
and the head elder were going through a
series of meetings that they were
getting ready to do an evangelistic
series so they were reviewing all
whatever 20 some present presentations
that they were going to do and so this
guy he's painting and he's listening to
like super condensed
all of our fundamental beliefs and
great controversy stuff and and
you know and and by wednesday
he has listened to all of it so monday
tuesday and wednesday and he's ready to
get baptized he's ready yeah
well that's the thing is is um this was
the expedited version yeah
he he actually told the pastor on
wednesday that he wanted to get
baptized and so the pastor comes home
and he's like
excited yeah and she's like alex live i
didn't i tell you we were doing so much
like this guy came in you know we told
him not gonna give money and so we
helped him out anyway and he's been
painting and he listened to our sermons
and he says wow this is the best that
i've ever heard i want to get baptized
in your church you know and i told him
that i've got missionaries in my house
and and he said that he really wants to
meet you guys so i told him that you're
going to go tomorrow and paint with him
and we're like
okay all right sure whatever well what
he said he needed to talk to us yeah he
did specifically which was interesting
because yeah he didn't know him and he
didn't know what he's like he needed
he's like i need to meet with those
missionaries at your house oh wow so i
mean i didn't think of it that way but
later on when we met him on thursday
like he's like i know why you're here
and so we're like
yeah the pastor told you we're
missionaries we're here praying he's
like
i know why you're really
here and he says i cannot tell you all
of the details because it's not safe for
me right now i'll tell you after i'm
baptized
and so we're looking at him and we're
kind of like you know and we had a
conversation with him
and and and on friday we did an outreach
and he went with us he's like no i'm not
gonna go up the other group i'm going
with the two of you and we walked into a
favela with this guy and this guy was so
at home oh wow so natural within this
favela and he wasn't even from this city
he acted like he knew everybody and he
was like
he
he was just we just thought he was a
phenomenal like dude you're going to be
an amazing soldier for christ you know
this is going to be great so after
sabbath um or on sabbath he gets
baptized after his baptism he's like
okay now i can talk to you so he takes
me and levi's side and our friend andrea
who's
came from she was one of those youth
from the previous city
they all came to fortaleza when they
heard that nobody there was willing to
do it they came up to spend time with us
and saying if you find somebody we will
train them when you're gone
but but that comes
that comes uh sunday night
um
we
we sit down me levi andrea and williams
and for like now it's my turn to listen
to the two to three hour conversation
and he begins breaking everything down
he's like saying listen
i like i come from a satanic family
we are all involved in the occult we're
all involved in secret societies like i
have uncle and some family members i
remember exactly in like the grand lodge
in sao paulo
uh masonic lodge and all this kinds of
stuff i remember all of the details but
he was he was connected within his
family
in some pretty
shady places
and and not low but fairly fairly high
and he said
um says i when i told you why i knew you
were here is because
the word goes around in that world
people are talking about
some missionaries yes
there's some missionaries here and this
is what they're doing so how do you
think that happened one of the people
you're witnessing to who probably
rejected the message went back told
there no no no no no no the the
impression that i got
was that
whoever was on the side of darkness or
lack of a better term knew
that somebody was in brazil doing this
all of that
all of them meaning that that the word
they were getting from the spirit realm
yes that that was the impression that i
got i don't know if i got a different
impression but it felt like not that
that it was broadcast per se but that
like it was kind of evident that
somebody is stepping within our
territory that is not from our territory
well i think
multiple people in these societies are
messing around with occult and
channeling and ouija boards whatever
whatever medium they're using they're
they're having communication with
spirits on a regular basis so they're
probably being told hey you need to
watch out for these guys what he also
revealed was that that they they can
sense
meaning that not everybody within a
favela but those that are i guess you
could say at the the higher echelons of
the hierarchy of
like the high priest of contemplate that
we met or whatever people who are
actually connected you know
through whatever rituals or or whatever
um
they can sense when somebody is there
and one of the things he told us
is he said do not walk into communities
with people
who just want to join you because it's
something cool to do their very presence
will weaken the the the atmosphere of
protection that you have and it's
visible
because when you guys walk into these
places you appear different to those
that are connected with spiritual
darkness
so there's there's there's like an aura
of light or something that appears
different to them and we've noticed that
there were times we would walk into
favelas where we just walk in
walk through and walk out and there were
people like
like this
very like would look at us and kind of
like
start but not really go anywhere
they would just stare at us until it was
gone and then frozen and then they would
just return
and and you know he he was saying a
number of different things like
you you guys have have basically marked
yourselves
you've shown up in a strong man's
territory trying to take his goods and
he doesn't take likely to
and
and he says you know you you you are
trying to take his property from him
those girls those boys those people they
belong to him they're his he thinks they
they're his
and when you're saying no they're not
yours and you're snatching them from
them
you're basically
you're declaring war on him
and he doesn't take lightly to that he's
going to try to destroy you either
through causing you to fall into sin or
killing you or whatever like just all of
these these warnings like i'm not here
to tell you to be afraid
i'm just telling you you know like he
just opened up like this whole
view into a similar kind of like a roger
moreno awakening into some of the the
the stuff that's going on he was
basically telling us
what you're doing you need to take
seriously
and because it it's
it doesn't appear as much outwardly i
mean people are like you're doing
what why would you pray
right that's true and it happens even in
our work we're like oh this will be a
cool video about doctor strange or
whatever and then you look in the
comments and there's people like
i went to that movie and i felt a
demonic presence i'll never go you guys
open my eyes and we're like we're really
making an impact in people's lives like
we're changing their whole mindset about
this media and stuff it's really is a
big important work even though sometimes
we don't see it that big i think it's a
thin veil like and once once you kind of
are privy to what's really going on the
spiritual warfare that that work is
around us all the time and it's like the
the sort of facade goes away and you see
it for what it is um yeah you can't
enjoy these things anymore because
you're just seeing what it is and i and
i imagine that you know anybody that's
that's fighting on the enemy's side they
realize that power is really in keeping
the deception alive and then the second
that that's pulled away well when when
we were down we uh after we got back
later this is just a little
snippet insert in here
um we went to do a presentation at
southern actually
um
and a guy came up to us after and told
us he grew up
with his his dad i think it was his dad
was into basically witchcraft stuff and
his ministry his prayer and like
deliverance he deals with sort of the
darker stuff
and he
said
something very similar he said when
people that are connected to that world
when they see
a person walking down the street they
know who the real christians are
and and he said because they can see
that person as if they have uh a weapon
spiritually they can see it visually
they know who happens
and he told us what was very important
is that
the ones who are
who they see as threats
are the the people who are prayer
warriors especially
and he said it's in direct relation to
how much a person is surrendered to god
so the more surrendered you are and the
more connected you are through prayer
with god and through scripture obviously
those are the ones that are
seen as threats you know in in the
spiritual world
so that's kind of not to take us off
topic but that was essentially the same
thing that williams had
talked to us about before there's this
idea of walking in the spirit like when
we talk about prayer warriors it doesn't
necessarily mean
like we're praying about stuff all the
time it's just learning how to
like you you begin the day with prayer
and
your devotion and drawing near to god
and asking him for direction you see now
i'm i'm going on my way
like guide my steps
and by the way i'm actively listening
and so you're going in a spirit of of
prayer that is visible that wherever you
are god is with
there's only so many things you could
say in
the span of you know 12 plus hours
during the day
so we're not just going crazy like that
like we're just
once we feel like and not not that it's
always about feeling but once we like
sense in into a certain measure that
our study our prayer was was sufficient
to prepare us for that day then we set
out on the day
and then we walk we're always you know
lord
is there something that you want me to
see
and it's just like
as if there was a third person with us
but we're asking him okay now we're
gonna walk down this street you know is
there anything that i should notice is
there a building is is there someone
within that third floor complex in that
window that i can't see that is
struggling right now you see beyond
there i don't know
and so i'm not going to pray according
to my own knowledge because all i can
see is the facade of the building but i
don't know who lives in there i don't
know if somebody is is is addicted to
drugs or something else or somebody is
going through a divorce or like we don't
know
but you do and we just want you to be
wherever we are yeah it's like you're
actively willing to invite god to guide
your steps where most people were just
like i'm gonna walk down the street
because that's what i want to do you're
opening up that conversation with god
like lord i want to do your will like
show me something and and like seeing a
promise and believing it and actively
showing your faith by doing it like lord
you said this i'm gonna do it you told
me to go here i'm gonna do it instead of
being like well give me a sign or
something it's like it's right there in
the word and you know it's it's kind of
easier to think about that when you go
elsewhere you're there for a mission
you know you're
you're there for that particular purpose
right then when we think about it like a
certain time period i'm going to be
there for a month i'm going to be on
fire yeah that's how it kind of works in
our minds but if you think about it when
we come back home why aren't we just
doing that in everyday life like you're
driving on your way to work why not be
in the same exact mindset there's
nothing special about
you know going to brazil to do that i
had that same thought as you were just
about ready to say that i just had
flashed in my mind yeah this is
applicable to us today i mean
we've got a lot of people that are
immersed in darkness all over this place
and uh you know do we sit there and have
those prayerful conversations like lord
you know i don't know why i'm going down
this street or i don't know you know why
i'm ducking into this store but you know
give me a divine um
interaction here one of the verses that
i think of and i know this is not the
direct application of that particular
verse but you know where where the
disciples are asking jesus why he's
speaking in parables and he says you
know that seeing they may not see and
hearing they may not hear unless they
should grasp hold of of eternal life and
um you know what what jesus had intended
by that is that he's saying things that
within them conceal the truth and if you
have the desire to search for them to
dig them up then you will find that
treasure so he's offering it to you but
if you're just going to accept it at a
superficial level then you're not
accepting it you actually have to dig
for it and and in the same way that i
think of christ i always have to ask
what is satan's counterfeit and he does
the exact same thing he presents to us
things that have
things behind them that we don't
actually dig out to find out well what
do you mean by that movie doctor
strangely so we're just receiving it but
seeing we don't see and hearing we don't
hear and we don't realize that we're
receiving a message from someone else
we're receiving doctrine from someone
else we're sitting influence from
someone or something else
and so in the same way if we live in a
superficial way we'll always be ignorant
of everything and so god is trying to
say hey listen you need to see beyond
that which is and you need to hear that
which is deeper than what is superficial
and if you don't have
that that that desire to know you're
going to remain ignorant and ignorance
is lost
i also think there's a danger too as as
you guys are bringing up doctor strange
and stuff too i think the more that you
you
you sort of put the blinders on the more
blind you become to the spiritual
warfare
and you know we battle people all the
time are you looking too deep into this
no i think we need to be looking deeply
into everything you become a perpetual
desire there is there is a lot of
spiritual warfare around us on a daily
basis
and the more that you just want to tune
out and like you know not sharpen that
communication the more you're not going
to recognize those those little
spiritual interactions that you need to
have and the thing is christians
deny
sometimes
the relevance of you know well isn't
that kind of a neutral thing or whatever
like right the relevance of everything
that everything has spiritually but on
the other hand
the enemy doesn't do that right right
you know we talked to a guy that grew up
um some couple years ago we were talking
to a guy on the phone that grew up
raised
to be like a high up
you know yeah yeah gabriel uh
in a high up position in the enemy's
work we would say
he's being groomed to be uh
international author to write books that
begin to incorporate huge demonic ideas
he was dedicated to satan before his
birth wow and he grew up
from
from a young age as soon as he was
school age four or five six whatever it
was
his mentors or his teachers every night
all night were directly spirits
direct there was no human teacher so he
was directly taught by spirits and he
told us
uh we talked to him on the phone about
this and he told us
one of the things now he's a christian
obviously
and he said one of the things that he
learned you know in those
lessons or whatever was that everything
in the world
had spiritual meaning every game every
sport every
interaction every you know there is no
new type of media yeah there's nothing
benign and it was interestingly as well
it was all based on the sanctuary that's
what these spirits evil spirits taught
him from the sanctuary in the bible and
from scripture and so strange has a
sanctum centaurum it says like when you
look that up that word it says the
jewish sanctuary he
his
dwelling in the high place is literally
called the sanctuary it's all a
counterfeit and everything everything in
life has some spiritual meaning behind
it but when we when we came back and we
started studying more into it to
understand kind of like a biblical
context of some of the things that we
were learning
um we came up with this idea uh that
that if god's process of salvation is
through the sanctuary then satan's
process of
of destruction is through a false
sanctuary so some reversal or perversion
of the sanctuary process right and we're
able
through the process of
of a prostitute going from being you
know a normal kid to becoming a
prostitute and then kind of entering the
cyclical you know downward spiral of
lifestyle
you know kind of overlaying it with the
steps of of the sanctuary but in a
perverted way in an inverse way we were
able to be like oh yeah that's that's
the process of taking somebody the way
that jesus takes us from where we are
outside the sanctuary to making us close
to him is the same way that satan does
corruption of the gospel
and everything yeah and then ezekiel 28
talks about you know lucifer and the
defilement of his sanctuaries and so we
started thinking about these things and
not to say that we have the most
comprehensive study on these things but
we've we've been looking at and we've
been trying to figure out and there's a
lot of what has helped us was that it's
not just a theoretical study there's an
overlap with things that we're seeing in
reality so it's not just something that
is purely conceptual it's it's like no
we can see this playing out we can see
this and you know
um
and it's like a tiny little shift like
you know what i mean like i think you
see it all the time it's just you when
you kind of become aware of it i
remember like when i first kind of
came back into a relationship with god
um and i lived in hollywood and and then
i would just look at the movie posters
that were all over and i was just like
how did i not recognize that how did i
not recognize that i think that you know
it's like all of a sudden you you just
open your eyes to the spiritual warfare
and and then you start recognizing these
little conversations these little people
that come into your space or your or
your your
um you know in your path and and it's
like like like god put that person right
there for you to have a conversation
with them and that could be a
life-altering conversation
and so you know to pray and and divine
ask for divine um guidance you know and
lord
help me help me to to just reach one
soul today and one person you know it's
like you'll see like your whole world
will turn upside down there's there's
there's uh you know one of the questions
that was asked earlier in one of the
other sessions was kind of like you know
what what can i do like how do i notice
somebody who's been trafficked or stuff
like that and i i hesitate to answer
that question not because if there
aren't like some set of criteria but
that that criteria could apply to people
who are not trafficked as well and so
it's kind of hard you know at times to i
guess you could diagnose because there
might be cross symptoms
um where somebody who is in that
situation is still
looks like they might be in that
situation and you jump to conclusions
and whatever it's it's it doesn't work
that way you
it has to do with building up the
sensitivity
you you spend time with god you spend
time with god in in in those particular
types of situations and all of a sudden
it goes beyond just noticing certain
flags to kind of like
you just
you walk through some place and you know
you meet somebody and you have a little
bit of an action it's just you're
building up that sensitivity for god to
be able to impress your mind in
situations that you've closed yourself
to in the same way that you would look
at that poster when you were far from
god there's nothing wrong with this and
all of a sudden you're close to god and
you're like wait a second why didn't i
see this before the same it's the same
image
but
the way that you view it is completely
different and so it's the same thing
like i can have you look at the same
person and i will look at them very
differently and that will be not because
you're not trained but because maybe
you just haven't
i don't spend time in that environment
or atmosphere with god you know in
dealing with that so
um well we often use the the analogy of
the counterfeit money you know you could
put that same counterfeit bill in front
of all of us and be like it's normal to
me and a banker comes in immediately
like that's not real because i spent so
much time with the real yeah yeah
i think you were
still talking about williams yeah yeah
so after after the conversation with
williams and this is kind of going to
illustrate it and i hope it doesn't
throw us for a loop here but after
williams after williams left um you know
i apologize to levi i apologize to
andrea i said you know i i've been
working in counter trafficking for years
and i came here to brazil and i kind of
took it a bit lightly and we were going
to pray and stuff like that and i knew
that there were greater
threats to what we were doing but i
didn't want to alarm anybody i didn't
want to scare anybody off
and you know we just decided that we
needed to pray and kind of just
recommit ourselves
you know just continue forward but just
you know keeping in mind a number of
things and so we started praying and
um you know i prayed and leave i prayed
and andrea was praying and while she was
praying
i began like all of a sudden just for
some reason like some darkness settled
in
and uh
i it was some scene of
fog mist
very little light
filtering just didn't massive your mind
in my mind yeah in my mind our eyes are
closed right and i just i see like this
dark blue like scene from a scary movie
kind of thing where there's this tree
whose branches spread to the horizon and
like the light is barely filtering
through the canopy like i can just
barely make out shapes you've got like
this fog
and i'm like
we're praying man like i don't know why
this is coming into my mind and all of a
sudden you know i've seen
i i hear
sounds and i hear clanging
metal clanging
what's going on here and so i look up
and i see
chains tied to branches and like
mannequins and dolls with no faces
roped about the neck with these chains
is just kind of like dangling swinging
under these like swaying branches and
i'm like
this is this is not what i should be
thinking
we're praying we're
you know we're
approaching god you know we're talking
to him i shouldn't be having dark eerie
scenes and i open my eyes
and it's there
i open my eyes and i still see the tree
and and these chains i'm still hearing
vaguely faintly like these sounds in the
background i can hear andrea pray but
i'm also hearing like these background
noises of
the trees swaying and chains clanging
and i'm like
what is going on i began slightly
panicking right i'm like
you know and so i'm bad it's gonna
happen yeah and i'm like i'm like okay i
can move i can move inside of this so so
i'm still kneeling but i'm moving inside
of whatever this thing that i'm seeing
and i began jumping up and grabbing the
chains and
pulling them down
but it doesn't do anything
like yeah some of these mannequins just
fall and lie lifeless on the floor i'm
just like dude this is creepy this is
like mad creepy
and like i'm weirded out i'm like
totally weirded out
and
and then finally i'm like i do what i
should have done from the beginning but
i didn't realize it was real or anything
i was just i was like god please just
just help me just let it go away i don't
know what this is
and the moment that i said god help me
like i noticed like the trunk of the
tree there was like this silhouette of a
man standing with like leaning on an axe
so it was an axe in his hand
and i'm like
yeah hmm my god give him give him
strength and he picks up the axe and he
begins like swinging at the base of this
tree and it's like
shaking violently like all the
reverberations through the branches and
the leaves and these chains and i'm like
i don't care just just chop down that
tree and i began interceding
and praying for for god to give strength
to this man to do it
and as soon as this tree like is felt
and it falls down it makes no sense
how this happened but once it falls down
all the branches are fanned out around
me so i'm like
okay it doesn't make sense but that's
the way it was
the tree was cut all the branches were
found out around me and now
the dolls and the mannequins were on the
floor and their chains were loose
so i began to unloose them now and they
disappeared
and well actually before that happened
before that happened i the first thing i
did was actually look up and i could see
the sky i could see the sun i thank god
and then i begin doing that and as soon
as i do the first chain
the whole thing just vanishes and andre
says amen
wow wow
this is what you're thinking during the
prayer vision
so they say amen they open up their eyes
and they see my eyes open and they're
like
you're all right
because i'm looking like i don't know
what i look like i probably look super
weird i mean it looks weird naturally
but i look weirder than normal it just
looked a little freaked out yeah yeah
white and so
like
something happened while we were praying
and i'm like uh
yeah yeah i think so
and so like i tell them and it didn't
take long that all three of us already
came to a conclusion of what it meant
and and the first thing that came to
mind was daniel chapter four
of the tree representing the kingdom
whose influence reaches to the end of
the world
and and what happens is that this
kingdom is so vast and it's so dark that
it allows very light to penetrate
it seems almost hopeless
and if we in our own power try to engage
in rescuing people which the mannequins
were adults and the dolls were children
the no faces means that to the system
they have no identity they have no value
as human beings they're commodities
they're objects
as soon as we try to
engage in some level of physical rescue
uber let's just get them out of the
slave industry or trafficking or
whatever it actually doesn't resolve
because the system is still there
there's no separation between the
influence that that
that that power that darkness has in
their life it's just taking them out of
the situation
it's just removing them oh i took you
off the streets okay but what about all
of that influence of darkness that is
inside of me that's still there
and so the moment that we cry out to god
for help he sends to us the real
intercessor jesus christ who's the only
one that can cut the system down
so when we intercede we're taking on in
essence christ's role as intercessor
right we're interceding on behalf of
people like he interceded on our behalf
and continues to intercede
so we're asking him to do for us that
which we cannot do for ourselves
that we can't do for others and he's the
one that actually begins to separate the
darkness and the whole that it has
inside that person remember that that
prostitute we talked to hosanna we
didn't do anything we didn't separate
her from the darkness god separated from
the darkness and then he brought us
together for us to finally just take the
physical chain off
but the work inside of her was already
done by god and so it's through
intercession it's through those types of
things that god begins to break the real
chains so that we can take the physical
chains
off i agree that's the work of the holy
spirit i think the holy spirit is the
one that's doing the real heartbreaking
conviction and you know we're just the
instrument to you know
be a vehicle for that to work through
sometimes and but it's really god that's
that's that's
that's opening their eyes that's you
know giving them the reality that
they're in
and uh you know it's neat to see god
work through you like that
it and it was just really just a
re-emphasis of everything that he had
been showing us already that the spirit
was saying i've gone before you i've
prepared the way
right like i did the planting the
growing whatever you just show up for
the hearts
that's
[Music]
which is um
you know the rest of
what we saw in that city
was that you know what i thought where
alex was going earlier was the night
before we were to leave that city
on sunday yeah yeah it was
um we were the pastor and
his
wife i think they stopped at somebody's
birthday party just on the way home
and um
it turned out that there was somebody
there that alex basically got in a
conversation with and who who was he was
uh with address yeah he worked for addre
so
they were just kind of chit-chatting you
know and
the guy expressed some interest though
in
this idea of going out
on streets and trying to reach out to
some of the people on the streets which
was a very sort of
there was a lot of pushback against that
in this particular city and church
to that point
so we we thought well we're going to
leave tomorrow
we're just not going to do it that's how
god you know god had other plans here
and
so he kind of went through it with with
the guy and at the end of the
conversation
he said well
we're gonna i'm gonna organize
a group
from you know the youth here and we're
going to go out and do it you know
there's another girl there that joined
us a little bit later in our
conversation his name was hadassah and
she she also the two of them said that
they were going to try to do it
jointly and then
yeah yeah so
we said well okay you know we'll just
leave it at that and if they do it they
do it you know we didn't think much of
it necessarily but so we left the next
day and a couple weeks later well the
group that we told you from the previous
city that we trained the group of young
people that we took on the streets they
came because they were there that
weekend they came that weekend to visit
us because you know
and andrea like i said she was one of
the one of these groups and they stayed
after we left and they trained this guy
in hadassah and a group of people how to
do it yeah so they actually ended up
doing it after we left yes
we were kind of surprised you know to
find that out
and so a couple weeks later we got a
phone call
um
from one of the people in that city and
they said
yeah
she said
i just got a phone call today because
we went out a couple weeks ago and we
did we did the project reaching out to
people on the streets here and i got a
phone call today
from one of the people that we met that
night because they had also um handed
out like she put their phone number she
said can i put my phone over but i said
that's a risky if you can take that and
go for it but she said that she felt
convicted i remember she did this this
was a city that
you know they said why are you doing
this there's no infrastructure
why would you go out and try to get
people off the streets
she said somebody called and said you
came out and you met me a couple of
weeks ago on the street
and you prayed with me
and
the night that you came and prayed with
me was my very first night in
prostitution
in my life
and she said i the same story actually
as the first lady we had met she said
i'm a single mom
and i don't have work i don't know what
else to do i have to provide for my kids
and i'm desperate
and so this is as my last resort i went
out and this was
going to be my solution
and she said when you when
you girls came out and prayed with me
when you left
the street she was on her way to her
first client wow she said when when you
left the street i realized
god didn't want me in it and i left too
and i never got into prostitution wow
because you they got her before her
first client
and so so it turned out in that same
church where they were asking that
question
they ended up getting a person off the
street and she ended up cleaning houses
for the people of that church as her you
know replacement work so she was like
she was like you put this number in this
card and i wasn't sure if you were real
or not but these weeks have passed and
i've done nothing
so i called kind of on a whim
can you help me and she's like you want
to clean my house
yeah i will and the other church members
they're like well have her come clean in
my house too they heard about it
and so all of a sudden you know this
person like
what are you going to do for them what
if it was prevention yeah what if you
could stop a person from going yeah yeah
she didn't need a place to stay she
needed money she needed something to
sustain her kids her husband had
laughter she had you know to me that's
the mercy of god like like what if all
that energy all that effort that you
guys were doing literally all of it was
leading up to just
one person
god would do that he would do that he
would literally send you on halfway
around around the world to go and
inspire somebody to go and reach out to
that one person
like the butterfly effect right you know
you think like what is this going to
help here and all of a sudden this this
catalyst of things happens down the road
and you know somebody gets their heart
saved
wow it's amazing
i would like to as i know we've got to
wrap this up here um
so i wanted to maybe mention just as
with that story and this you know
experience this is only the fourth city
so you know we have eight more but oh
well
not now you do need to write a book by
the way
because you can handle it a book um
but i wanted to just say you know
just the things we've talked about
are enough to say
the first really
weapon that we have the first thing like
that the tip of the spear you know
should be god
and the spiritual and through prayer
right
because you you can see the difference
sort of when we go
let's say and do
an evangelistic series that's a good
thing right that's obviously
you know we're going out and we're
preaching the the sermons and all that
but if we're going to do that in a
community let's say that hasn't been
prayed for first
we're kind of like going against a wall
because we don't know what walls are
there spiritually right
right and so you're going into battle
with like little to no armor yeah yeah
you know
and and so one of the things that
we kind of learned or thought about you
know god taught both of us i think
through a lot of illustrations in
scripture especially
and
when
you think about putting
prayer as a first thing
breaking down the walls spiritually as
the first thing
um
you could compare it to like you know
back in the old days when they used to
go out with swords and you know spears
and shields and all that
like medieval times you know maybe
um
there were
different units types of units that they
would
use essentially in warfare some were
close range you know maybe like the
swordsman
um
some were uh long range the archers
that would have been me yeah far away
yeah i'll shoot them
but you could see them like their eyes
right the concept like one of the
concept is that many of us like we'll
we'll engage in in
kind of one-on-one combat kind of thing
like let's say we're giving a bible
study obviously we're not combating that
person but we're combating the ideas in
their life in a sense right so you can
consider that one to one
and so like oftentimes as a church we
overemphasize the swordsman position
where everything is a swordsman position
but like the moment you get to like what
about
slavery what about like these really big
issues
or things that are hidden
let's call it whatever stronghold there
is there's multiple strongholds some are
bigger some are smaller but let's say
that you want to go against a stronghold
are you going to take swordsman against
a stronghold right that's like an
exercise in futility like you don't you
don't go and you start hitting a wall
stone with swords stone and swords don't
don't combine very well right and so you
know if if i were to take my soldiers
against like an enemy line let's say not
one person but like
a group of people i still wouldn't send
my soldiers first
i would send archers first thin out the
lines then send my my you know my sword
my soldiers or spearmen or whatever into
a broken flank right like i'm not i'm
not going to just oh go ahead and see
who wins you know shield against shield
spear against beer i'm going to send my
arrows first thin it out create gaps
right and then send my my shoulders to
to break them and
spread them apart but even even
archers i wouldn't take against the wall
i'm just going to bounce off the wall so
what do you what do you bring in you
bring siege weapons
and and the granddaddy of siege weapons
is a trebuchet right catapults
trebuchets that's the thing that throws
the rock yeah yeah so like the trebuchet
is is is the mother of all catapults
like it just
it can catapult the catapult um
much longer range and the the idea is
that
we will we will say that swordsman is
interpersonal
work evangelism studying
talking with people being their friends
it's just that one-on-one kind of thing
and sometimes it can happen in groups
you know
and then you have archers archers are
people who who send the attacks first
you pray first you begin to create gaps
where where you know once again it's not
talking about aggression this is just
talking about like you know somebody has
certain belief systems so why not why
not if you're going to do evangelize to
a community why not pray that god breaks
down certain mindsets jesus reached into
their life before you even go and talk
to them right jesus illustrated this
idea basically with breaking the the
soil first right
yeah
that's what i'm listening to yeah i'm
thinking planning too is like there's a
science to right you know you're not
going to just plant everywhere just like
i like the illustration of like not
going up and using your sword everywhere
in certain circumstances that's not the
best plan of attack right so yeah i mean
i'm i'm seeing those i mean when you
think when you when you think of david
david is a complete warrior he uses the
slang long rage and the sword close
range yeah he uses the sling to break
down you know he's accused of like you
know am i a dog that you come to me with
like sticks and staves and and david
says i'm coming to you with with weapons
or spear i'm coming to you in the name
of the lord so he brings him down first
in the name of the lord and then he cuts
off his head with the with the sword
so the battle is yeah the battle is one
because god delivers him you know who
are you right that you should defy the
gods of heaven the god of heaven god
will deliver you into my hands
so it's not like i'm going to beat you
it's god will deliver you and so that
long range that that preparedness
beforehand where god says the victory is
yours i'm going to hand it to you oh by
the way he's on the ground now so go
ahead and take his sword and cut his
head off
there's there's a every single one of us
to be complete warriors we have to have
both the long range and the short range
but just kind of we need to you know uh
talking about siege weapons siege
weapons are what you use for strongholds
and siege weapons are not mobile like
like archers
right so it still is prayer but it's in
a different context than you would as an
archer where you are mobile or single
right you have to do it in a group you
cannot run a trebuchet by yourself it
takes a team of people
and you do not pepper a wall you hit one
spot you create that vulnerability to
the breaches made and then you send your
soldiers into that breach to bring down
whatever is behind that wall and so what
we've kind of said is that that are
those are people who say that they're
going to stay in an area they're going
to occupy a certain place and continue
to hammer at one particular thing until
the answer is made the breakthrough
happens that would be just like little
light studios and hammering movies over
and over and over again till we break
down that wall that's that's the purpose
of the spiritual
you're not trying to pepper everything
and you're just like oh we got this and
that whatever like you're staying in one
place and saying lord we want to create
a resolution in this particular fortress
and that idea of
group prayer is you know and ha that
having a specific particular purpose and
particular efficacy is actually you know
matthew 18 that's idea right if two or
three are gathered in my name
i'm there in the midst of them um jesus
gave some
you know particular emphasis to that he
said that whatever you ask
if you agree together in my name then
it'll be given to you it's also in the
book of acts where they had gathered
together to pray while peter was in
prison and they literally that was a
fortress and god made a breach in the
voyages opened all the doors and put
everybody asleep so that he could walk
out and they kept on praying to the
point that even after he arrived they
couldn't stop praying like is that
really him you know yeah hold on peter
we're still praying for you peter all
right so it you know and and in
practicality how does this look well i'm
going to give you two examples one in
atlanta
is
uh i knew this story it happened while i
was there but but i wasn't necessarily
part of it but
there was a ministry that was praying
for our work 24 hours a day they had a
church
and they said our purpose is to pray for
wherever our churches whatever community
our church is in and for what you're
doing so we're going to put
we're going to plant a church we're
going to buy a building in this part of
town where we know that trafficking is
happening we're going to pray for this
this part of town and we're going to
pray for your ministry that is reaching
out to victims of trafficking
and we're going to have somebody in our
church or a group of people in our
church around the clock that our church
will never be empty there will always be
people praying 24 7 for your ministry
and for this neighborhood
and the people that were scheduled to
pray between the hours of uh i remember
exactly like ten after ten and like five
in the morning or four in the morning
uh i had trouble because on the other
side of the blocker street there was
like a club that had blurring music and
stuff like that it was super loud a lot
of thumping and whatever and so the
people that were there just like i uh
get a headache i can't hear myself so
they said either we go somewhere else or
or we scream they said well we've come
here to pray so we started yelling their
prayers wow people just say well we're
not if you're loud we're going to be
louder kind of though they just started
and and and they did that for over a
year wow they just they had people in
that church for over a year praying 24
7. and finally there was like some sting
on on the club and the owner was
arrested it was shut down and the city
shows up and says would you like this
building as your new church building
took my territory we'd like to give it
to you
they're like yeah we don't want anybody
else occupying they'll start up another
club right and so while they're cleaning
it out they find trap doors in the floor
and they go and there's this hidden
basement and then there's like these
dividers and there's torture devices oh
wow
people were going there and they were
they were they were prostitutes they
were
they were torturing people and tons of
like there's some freaky fetishes and
stuff like that did they know what was
behind that wall they did it but god
knew what was behind them well all they
knew that their part was to continue
hammering and trying to grab your
up they said
and they kept on hitting that wall until
it was brought down wow and then we took
this concept after brazil
and we took it to a group in tennessee
uh right here um and uh
a group here in chattanooga and they
said you know teach us kind of what you
did and so we're going to teach you how
to pray
something that god reveals but but yes
there's principles so we'll tell you
what we did and you apply it and we went
to a part of chattanooga where we knew
that there was stuff going on
and we walked through here's a
seedy motel here's an adult club
adult store here's a nightclub here's a
truck stop here's a neighborhood with
boarded up windows all
in the same area so we just walked
around them and you know i said hey do
you see these boarded up houses yeah
nobody lives here there's nothing going
on here don't be so sure
let's jump the fence oh there's shell
casings you might find a needle be
careful don't step on anything right
just because they're abandoned doesn't
mean there aren't people going there
using them as drug houses and stuff like
that this neighborhood is right behind
you know
all this stuff the the the truck stop
and the adult store and the club
and i said you guys
you dedicate this place you come here
every sabbath right after church and you
group just pray for it and they did so
for six months and then we got a call
saying listen that adult shop was closed
down
that neighborhood was bulldozed
in six months
wow and they don't know why the adult
shop was shut down but the adult shop
was shut down the neighborhood was
bulldozed and they had a new development
project and so it was just
you know we don't know like i don't know
what happened i don't like but you begin
to to see that if you
commit to something you notice it and
and you put in these principles that
there's going to be a result wow
wow man well that's been super
encouraging like these stories just
i mean i'm i'm ready to go hit the
prayer closet right now right it just
makes you think about all the things
that you could be doing yeah i mean i've
been really impressed lately like this
year to to focus on intercessory prayer
god's really been showing me the power
of intercessory prayer how
moses pled with god about the israelites
who were worshiping idols and god
changed his mind he wanted to destroy
the israelites but it said that god
changed his mind because of moses um
abraham prayed for a lot and his family
who were not worthy they were going to
be destroyed with sodom and gomorrah but
angels pulled them out because of
abraham's prayers and jesus being nailed
to a cross praying for those people
tortured them father forgive them they
know not what they do
so all those kind of stories and what
you guys are saying just really just
adds
fuel to that spiritual fire in me to
keep praying intercessory prayer man
prayer works i want to encourage you
guys to keep praying don't
give up on anybody i mean i used to be
one of those people that christians
looked at and said that guy's way too
far going man he's gothic where his
pantyhose and fingernail polish and all
that stuff and i'm thinking about these
stories these people
who are just at the end into their rope
you know they're they don't know how
they're going to make
how they're gonna feed their kids what
they're where they're gonna stay tonight
whatever and most of these people aren't
entering into this because they want to
it's not because they choose to be
either they're
forced into it
because of
some situation that they're in or
because they're being trafficked and so
i think it's amazing what you guys are
doing it's really encouraging and makes
me want to go out there i know i have a
cousin she goes to uh a strip club with
some other ladies and they just
you know they just talk to the girls and
pray with them and stuff and it's
there's amazing stories so i hope this
has been encouraging i hope it's been
eye-opening i hope it's brought some
awareness it sure has for me if you guys
uh think of somebody in your life that
needs to see this please share this
video and don't forget to click a simple
thumbs up it really helps get this into
the algorithm and subscribe to us so you
can keep up with more content like this
and we cannot thank our supporters
enough because we could not survive
without you guys so we will see you guys
next week thank you
[Music]
you